so let's take a look so we start off in
what appears to be Africa yeah this will
be socks you forget that we 5oc Toy
Story this whole Pinkamena next door the
film begins with the master of modern
day B movies himself bruce campbell who
is so cool that every time someone
mentions his name a man is cured of
impotence johnny-on-the-spot basic laser
yeah I just shit this out of my ass i
shit guns that's how cool I am so he's
talking to a member of the CIA who also
happens to be his fiancee named Karen
played by Laura Lee very rarely turns in
a bad performance we looking for some
sort of rare diamond that apparently can
charge their laser guns to the nth
degree
I read you Charles well you wreaking all
that I found the bloody thing what was
that
okay acting it's okay I make a living
out of it they're under the orders of
Joe Don Baker who quite frankly has a
lot of other bad movies he could be
starring in kitchen but things look bad
when Campbell's partner Jeffrey goes a
little too deep into the jungle
but now you're throwing stuff at me come
on Jeffrey stuff for their eyeballs at
me why and yes that's the last we see of
Bruce Campbell in this movie I know at
least you got choked up Baker
so once they find out the crew seems
mostly dead Joe Don Baker doesn't react
very well
Darren Melville never beat Evil Dead
Thor I need those diamonds dr. oz this
satellite is our communications cash-cow
I need a new cash machine this diamond
this is it Charles knew that that's why
I went down to that godforsaken place
jor-el's went into the Congo to please
you I know you had feelings for it I was
married him for Christ's sake meanwhile
we got to our main character a young
scientist named Peter it's happened
before
gorillas in captivity degenerating
mentally having to be destroyed
hi I'll be you're not quite Steve
Guttenberg for the movie he's broken new
ground because he's devised a way to
communicate with gorillas through sign
language and has even made a machine to
give them a voice Amy could you come
down here please
why hello obvious person in a gorilla
suit oh good gorilla oh pretty this is a
talking gorilla Moira this is really
happening
this isn't mr. ed oh it's not mr. ed no
doubt there show this miracle to the
finest minds in scientific research
their final conclusion this is not mr.
ed Wow
food for thought huh but Peters
concerned because Amy keeps painting the
same pictures of an eye on some trees
what could this mean Peter uses all his
brilliant scientific knowledge to figure
it out
what's this room starting to look like
it's the jungle she's been painting the
jungle oh boy so just to recap talking
aids denied equal talking horses and
drawings of jungle equal drawings of
jungle I can tell just gonna be blown
away by this movie's intellect so Peter
wants to return Amy to the jungle but
his boss doesn't want to really fund now
there isn't a foundation in motion that
would fund an expedition with that
objective
I will pay I will pay for Amy to go home
I'm sorry they're filming rocky and
bullwinkle next door
your accent Solaris though herkermer
Homolka formerly of Romania free now of
the chains of Ceausescu traveling the
world doing good
really you're supposed to be in this
movie so yeah Tim Curry plays a Romanian
fruitcake once too fun Peters travel to
Africa the idea so ludicrous that even
the characters have a hard time buying a
Romanian philanthropist amar Homolka in
something's voodoo don't look a gift
horse in the mouth okay granted he
certainly does look like a gift horse
I'll get you that Safari I don't even
like picnics that's right
jungle tickle tickle tickle okay let's
not jump to any conclusions um maybe
this is a game they like to play or
maybe 2/8 this is like the equivalent of
Gibraltar or maybe there's some sort of
other kind of things would only stop
saying that oh so just as they're about
to leave Karen comes along to join the
adventure in the hopes of finding her
fiance you've been putting together
rather hasty expedition to Congo the
talking gorilla
Charlie that's right the jungle jelly
just a minute I'm convinced their
strange obsession with monkey tickling
can only lead to one conclusion at one
conclusion only to promote their brand
new line of toys Tickle Me Baby tickled
her and she says just the most adorable
things pick up Amy
it's a Jim dorable tickle Amy
Lois she's so cute grab Amy's genitalia
spank Amy spank a me hard call Amy bad
girl shit on Amy shit on Amy's face give
Amy golden shower fuck Amy fuck Amy for
hours Amy love you long time
so Karen also funds peter's trip as they
make their way to Africa
that animal dangerous humans are
dangerous guerrillas very gentle well
are you so certain there aren't some
kind of gorillas that kill please doctor
you can't be serious is that way the
movies described as head and killer Apes
innit till we get off the plane and are
greeted by a guide clay by Joe
Pantoliano a talking gorilla I feel that
money has on the back of my neck going
whoa whoa whoa hi I'll be your Italian
douche bag and every movie that I'm in
but they're also joined by another guy
played by early Hudson who is hands down
the coolest guy in this movie though
even Bruce Campbell's courts as a few
drops of coolness left Monroe Kelley I'm
your great white hunter for this trip
though I happen to be black I just made
that lens oh cool oh yeah you're some
kind of criminal aren't you don't we all
I'm not a criminal I'm a scientist I run
a few guns you sons of bitches
ruined the world I've transformed myself
into a black Clark Gable and quite
frankly my dear I don't give a damn
though this really begs the question how
can an actor who's obviously so cool
like Ernie Hudson think a movie about
killer gorillas and talking monkeys
could possibly be good if there's a
steady paycheck in it I'll believe
anything you say
but to get caught by the new African
government of the last six minutes as
one of the military leaders has a talk
with them have some coffee and cake have
some I made it myself
stop eating my sesame cake that is for
dessert these tea party is ruined
so after they pay their way through we
get to hop on yet another plane for
traveling
somehow I think this is who I expense
you're right
they say the tickling of the ape is
creepy and weird you will sit in the
back
so the plane takes off but it's quickly
shut down as our heroes have to get out
and fast get out of this stink idle and
in one of Michael Crichton's theme park
movie shadows usually do well where's
Amy
now she's asleep she's over there all
the way down she decided to wake up and
let me tell you that little lady has
some set of teeth look I'm sorry we're
gonna have to call this off call it off
that's like being on the Hindenburg I
want to go refund this is Karen Ross
Houston Travis do you read I read and
see you dr. Ross you've got to hurry
that region in the virunga's is bad okay
calm down
guy the answer to everything is some
shouting at TV screens okay all right
calm down calm that blow look you want
me to order a pizza
excellent all right Iran ordering a
pizza here we go
hello hi yeah I would like one large
pepperoni pizza please
what oh all right Oh
hold on there uh they're out of
pepperoni pizza oh so our heroes sit
back and enjoy the strange sounds of the
wilderness is that what is that mating
season does a moon like that every
monkey for 200 miles thinks he's Elvis
Presley
all right will be when you want to make
sense of that scene just give me a call
at that number cuz I'd love to know what
the hell you're trying to get across
okay stop Oh somebody help me
what is it something I might look like a
creature of growth or something um
that's your penis oh that's a leak so
take it off I'm gonna take it off as
your lead you take it off it's in half
come go giant Apes of the jungle and
leeches that feast on Pinay I'm so glad
I paid 850 to see this but it turns out
they're leaching P model disorder is
being watched don't indicate you see me
zoom a ghost trial thankfully I happen
to be a Ghostbuster so there's no
problem allama Gekko heavy he says
there's a dead white man in his forest
with a symbol on his clothes
it's travicom the company I work for the
me zoom will have several levels of dead
someone's not dead until they're
completely dead is it big difference
between mostly dead and all that so they
come across the ghost tribe where they
try their mystical chance to bring the
man back to life
where is the man well gee my guess is
that area they're all pointing to and
chanting at might be in the general
direction huh I was right too cheap to
look at I have seen better suits at
Spencer's goodbye so after that bit of
subtlety they head up River where Tim
Curry finally confesses what he's
looking for I suppose there's no point
in playing stupid no please you've been
doing it so well as a young man I found
a book in Soviet Georgia it contained a
detailed drawing of the city of Zinj
it's always been believed that King
Solomon had a diamond mine in the Congo
in a city phone was in the drawing
contained a peculiar decoration and open
I later on safari I found this my prize
in my Fruity Pebbles cereal the gorilla
drew this it is the same image it is the
open eye yes because no one would
everything to draw and I that gorilla
has seen the city of Zinj and she will
take us there I originally thought he
was infirm going but this time I'm
definitely sure it's you so while we're
rowing on this beautiful day for night
they can't help but feel like they're
being followed
so they scare off the evil hippopotamus
and continue to move forward what's she
doing she wants to go to the blessing
her heart okay can we just replace to
encourage dialogue with a laugh track
cuz that's all you're gonna hear anyway
we must follow that gorilla when she
lays gorira gorila right that door and
find the nuclear Wessels then they come
across a terrifying discovery
if you run he'll chase me I know I've
read the books
this must be while this rally gorillas
he was talking about early so even
though the garlic doesn't hurt him Amy
tries to see if she can communicate with
them hello hi hi Amy good good whatever
that was straight
what the hell was she talking about a
power glove wearing freak so the search
goes on as they finally come across the
camp that Karen's fiance was at
bitch it is the city of Zinj that I have
looked for all my life my accent just
orgasms and it see the eyes
it is the same and last I have been
being dictated and in a surprising
letdown there's nothing there but a fat
Marlon Brando reading pretentious poetry
done errand boy sent by grocery clerks
in the Diamonds flow to the kingdom of
Solomon so what happened why the city
died I don't know maybe the mines ran
dry no no no no oh excuse me I'm just
bouncing up my tuna sandwich oh wow
the diamonds are here and queer and not
going anywhere
so while looking through the kingdom of
the crystal doll they come across the
room of diamonds but are unfortunately
trapped there as well
they also come across the body of
Karen's fiance it's him it's him so ash
is ash but to make things worse the
guardians of the diamonds these
radioactive albino yachts come in to
smash our hero
hmm what is that line Peter set for
earlier humans are dangerous
gorillas very gentle well are you so
certain there aren't some kind of
gorillas that kill oh please doctor you
can't be serious
luckily I think Amy comes along to save
the day I'm a gorilla I'm good oh gosh
II mean there are we really ugly Amy I
cannot believe she said that I guess we
could bash your brains in seeing how
we're twice her size but gosh Diane I'm
just so hurt
so Karen grabs one of the diamonds and
loads it into her laser gun hoping
you'll be powerful shit is that cool
okay Bruce Campbell Ernie Hudson and
that fucking gun are the only cool
things in this movie unfortunately a
monkey no explodes which means our
heroes have little time to get out of
there Hey look a pause let's jump in
flash
so Karen manages to contact her boss and
let him know what's going on did you get
it I bad news Charles he's he was killed
did you get that diamond summer meets
offer me I don't know where that comes
from I'm usually a very nice guy I have
no good job do you remember what I told
you if I ever knew you sent me here for
some diamond and not for Charlie that I
would make you sorry yeah well I just
figured you're on the rag
so she decides to take her laser gun and
destroy the satellite that's keeping the
company alive that's nice thousands of
people lose their jobs but at least
Judah Baker is toted listen as Peter
sets Amy free into the wild and they
ride off in a hot-air balloon
ah look you can see any burning to death
and the volcanoes laughs look at her now
here would you do me a favor what you
throw this away from me
you sure there it's gone there's a wind
I hope it blows us someplace good me too
oh it will it'll blow you into the
happiest place I can think of at the
moment and credits God it seems like
they took forever
so that's Congo it sucks TV more the
special effects are just silly the
cornball storyline is laughable the only
good things in it are Bruce Campbell
Ernie Hudson the net eight zapper figure
but on the right side a dick give birth
to tickle me Amy
it isn't that reward enough stop
tickling Amy I love it stop tickling Amy
now isn't she so cute
stop tickling Amy or Amy will smash your
head in
with rock and piss on your core is
nostalgia critic I remember so you
better run motherfucker
stop eating my sesame cake